The book describes five creational patterns.
Their names are singleton, prototype, builder, factory method and
abstract factory.
In a minute we will look at the singleton pattern.
The prototype pattern is a way for
designers to make use of a different kind of inheritance.
Most object oriented languages provide class based inheritance.
But some languages like LISP, provide a different way to inherit.
Instead of inheriting from classes, you inherit from other objects.
The prototype pattern tells you how you might get that same
facility within a class based language.
The builder patterns gives you a way of separating the actual construction of
the object from how it's pieces are built.
Factory method is a way that let's the sub classes decide
which class to instantiate.
The framework as a whole merely ask for creation.
Specific creation is done by a concrete factory.
And if you want to apply this method to a set of related classes,
you can use the abstract factory pattern.
For example, user interface tool kits may allow you to specify the look and feel
of a set of widgets, and the abstract factory has a way of accomplishing that.